vous savez j'adore le japon est en ce
moment j'essaie d'apprendre le japonais
enfin quand j'ai en ce moment ça fait
dix ans que j'essaie je ne progresse pas
en fait mon japonais est resté au niveau
animé n'ont ni support et london ayoka
huahine non non vous dire ça ne sert pas
trop quand je vais au japon et la chasse
et non n'y a ni tanguay benchenane
dessus nihon des rois chicago qui tous
deux saouls toshi tezuka wall a été élu
to you coteaux au shit et images taka
yoga tai chi au courant ok j'appelle les
flics déjà à l'école j'étais pas très
très fameux pour les langues et je me
suis pas aidé puisque j'ai choisi
allemand lv1 de mon plein gré je ne
m'explique pas déjà c'est une langue
impossible à apprendre voilà ce n'est
pas possible
et puis comparé à l'anglais c'est pas la
langue la plus utile à vous en doutez en
fait quand j'ai choisi allemand a levé 1
quelle était ma vision du monde
exactement des états unis ça me parle
pas par contre l'allemagne halal match
d'hier dans 10 ans toute la planète sa
part l'allemand
et si j'avais dit j'ai mis des sous de
côté et rappelle j'ai tout investi tout
cas ça à oui mais je garde pourtant bon
les cours de langue je comprenais rien
c'était une souffrance mais il ya pire
les bilingues au lycée j'avais un pote
américain je ne sais pas comment il
faisait pour supporter les cours
d'anglais
ça devait être horrible les cours
d'anglais vu par les bilingues tenez
l'exercice du jour vous avez une heure
de paris c'est l'autre ou non mais j'y
viens je passe trop dur pendant c'est le
trou à côté par good cyprien goût very
good on applaudit cyprian [ __ ] je suis
trop bilingue jason d'applaudir aux
camarades
gp le carré à wimbledon
en fait c'est après l'école que je me
suis mis sérieusement l'anglais pour le
travail pour les voyages fin c'est quand
même primordial bon à l'allemand et au
final je trouve que l'anglais c'est une
langue plutôt simple à apprendre je peux
même les étrangers qui veulent apprendre
le français quand ils ont créé l'anglais
le français
les gars qui sont pas partis dans le
même délire anglais pour la conjugaison
du verbe être tu as fait comment
exactement sa voix basse et ayane et
ensuite c'est la même chose quoi you are
we are they are not allowed je suis
partisan de délire déjà c je suis donc
nous suit son nous sommes vous sommet
alors vous êtes il est
ils sont on s ent mais le t2 sont ne
fait pas de son tu dis un ou une canapé
tâte encore tu as donné des genres aux
objets habitat raison pourquoi j'ai fait
ça ça et ça donc c'est à lors du pont
aux cartes non non ça se prononce à sous
le sais j'ai mis une petite queen le dit
une petite couilles j'ai l'impression
que tu me juger anglais alors oui j'ai
choisi allemand a levé 1 j'ai pas trop
compris pourquoi mais je comprends
encore moins ceux qui choisissent
d'apprendre une langue qui n'existe plus
et des gens qui choisissent d'apprendre
le latin c'est une langue morte
un donc sa annonce un petit peu
l'utilité d'apprendre cette langue et tu
dois rester plus longtemps après les
cours c'est quoi le seul argument qu on
sort enfin de la seo servira à prendre
plus facilement une autre langue
autant prendre le temps que tu passes
apprendre le latin pour apprendre
directement une autre langue
ogawa gâtés qui enclenche je suis désolé
je ne vois pas une situation où le latin
te servir
ça fait deux jours qu'on a enfermé dans
ce ton bon on va crever attends je crois
qu'une inscription là pour ouvrir la
porte
quoi ouais salaires des du latin oui
hier j'ai vu trois ans de latin au
collège c'est du grec quoi c'est du grec
[ __ ] mais pourquoi tu as fait
l'intérêt je sais pas j'ai pas dit qu
eva super on va mourir à cause de toi je
suis finalement elle veut aussi mais
pourquoi je ne sais pas quand je
m'exprime dans différentes langues
j'ai remarqué que j'avais un baromètre
de galère plus je galère plus j'utilise
les mains galère niveau 1 clairement
prend pas assez en compte la congo
lexicaux baptisation des lois du marché
avec les lois en vigueur
à un moment il faut se réveiller galères
niveau 2 6 me de news avant tout que
deux beach wind in the way the beach
hockey c'est une galère niveau mille
mange mange et tab et masta démarche
amène le la mène là mais nuisent à aix
notamment gotta lago ici qu'est rio
gaillac attaqué au colloque un truc qui
m'insupporte quand apprend une langue
c'est les mecs qui se foutent de ta
gueule parce que tu t'es un peu trompé
en parlant il a dit la canapé au lieu de
le canapé passe trop la honte me direz
vous à ce sont les mecs qui savent
parler qu'une seule langue qui font ce
genre de réflexion vous freiner les
efforts des gens qui essaye d'apprendre
une autre langue
mettez des oursins dans votre slip ya
pas de blague n'a pas de lag non c'était
juste fait sa sortie pour apprendre le
japonais chevalet sur youtube super site
en passant j'ai trouvé plein de gens qui
t'apprennent leur langue c'est hyper
pratique cependant je suis tombé sur
d'autres vidéos qui m'ont totalement
découragés comme angers a pris 5 l'an
comment j'ai appris à parler sinon
comment j'ai appris à parler cette
langue
jusqu'où ça va aller point commun entre
ces youtuber aucun ne parle latin
encore des fautes de français il parle
quoi neuf langues ans pour me rassurer
je me dis que voilà ils doivent
ressembler à des l'icann est là négligé
qui passent leur vie selon bouquin ça
freine tchanilé beau gosse musclé en
plus si par neuf long je suis une merde
[ __ ] j'y arriverai jamais en sortant
du coma un australien parcours à moins
de monde 1
tim d'un grave accident de la route un
australien de 21 ans s'est réveillée
d'un coma en parlant couramment le
mandarin
c'est ça que je veux faire
[Musique]
méfiez vous venez d'avoir un accident là
est ce que ça va donc crû de bono je
comprends pas ce que vous dites
yapo nika lokole sais quelle langue ça
couine latine et nono coundoul je suis
désolé mais l'allemand est la langue la
plus parlée en europe je sais c'était de
l'humour de latin c'est aussi apprendre
la culture et l'étymologie c'est c'est
eh bien il est prof de josai c'était de
l'humour abonne toi
[Musique]